皆様
大きくも小さくもない中どんなこの博士をありがとうございます
0x &卒業にばしていい広める価値のあるがいりあ
我々その画期的なアイディアを皆様にお伝えすることを大変楽しみにしてまいりました
それがこの
私入場からもう一度やり直しますので
最大の拍手でお願いします皆様は歴史の目撃者となります
広める価値のアイディアですあの地帯の人たちはモンティお願いしますじゃあ
代金請求者を監視
我々
働くエンターテイメント集団
昼は
休養も効率よく稼ぎ
夜祭日祝日週末は謎の
エンターティメント集団
そしてパパ区エンターテイメント集団
ただ xt 広める価値のアイディア我々は給料のが過ぎ方どう
この場の盛り上げ方以外伝え方を知りません
よってしゃべったりはあまりいたしません
muse ま
どうか大きな拍手でお迎えくださいいい
アーチい裏起動
dare
これは戯曲でです
ええええええ
car
me
ええええええ
dee
uh
me
皆様あらためまして0x 圧倒
それはいればシティ
え我々黒星生じあるためブラックスターズメンバーの講演会へご来場いただきまして誠
にありがとうございますありがとうございます
親戚でもの祈りありがとうございます
広める価値のある my dear 6そんな
各界著名人の皆様がですね
何と言いますか素晴らしいアイディアをこの場で3時間以上を渡ってせ見上げてきた
この聖なるんね
素晴らしいこの空気をその後を取りを使えますのがもの
なんとか難病バズーカみたいな
言われであることをまずはここにお詫び申し上げさせていただきたいかと思います
我々流の皆させ方だから仕方のをしていきたいと思いますが皆さん誠意が伝わりまし
たら大きな拍手をお願いいたします
あっもちろん魔女さまでナビしてませんかなぁもぅしてませんか
そうだな
誤りの独立の増収だった
栃木はやめたまえ
大捧げ
今のはぎりぎりの8うまく中央してこの2人がよぎるというちゃんとした演出です
そうですね黒てもう一つ紹介することでございます我々
広める価値のあるアイディア画期的なアイディアを思いつきました
全米が震撼するアイディアを思いつきましたような表紙で powerpoint の
そしてみなさまへのスピーチ
ねをナビの朝礼のスピーチを考えてきたんですけどもねこちらの方に ipad が
ございまして
この時間が刻々と迫っております
時間の都合上までパフォーマンスをしなければなりませんのでスピーチそしてその
パワーポイントのプレゼンボラボラ全て買ったという形に
になりましたのでそこ大往生ですね
もう一つをこねさせて頂きたいかと思います
そうな
パンッ
赤のか体育会系のか欲しいな注意
人はやめたまえ
そして
この価値のあのシティに立たせていただく事をおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおおお
礼を申し上げさせていただきたいかと思いますありがとういうのが武器な
第ていくん
皆さんに感謝の気持ちを急いません
予定では僕で浸透する技たんですか予想以上の反響を頂きまして誠に有難うございます
さあ
人生は思い通りになります
これは僕の師匠の受け売りですがここで皆さんにやってほしいことが出ます
会場により皆様ようにするっていただきたいと思いますよちょっと目を作っていたで
よろしいですか
増車するわかりますからね s わかりますからはい
愛ですね
僕の党員に対してもうアンチ
である方は税を上げていただきたいと思いますもう一度聞きます
人生はメモるの無理になる
ああなるほど思い通りにならないと思う方々が悪い人ばっかりですね
敗3分けでいるで結構です人生は思い通りにならないと思っていた
人生は思い通りにならないでしょう
思い通りになってるんですだって人生思い通りにならないと思って思い通りになって
ないんですかそれはつまり思い通りになっているんです
お分かりですか暖かいさすが早々に伸ばしてありがとうございます
偏差値が高いそういうことでございますつまりモードになるのであればやりたいことを
やりたいですよ
つまり夢追いたいでもやりたくないこともある買わなきゃいけない
やりたくない仕事もしなきゃいけない辛い事だってあります
やりたいことやりたくないこと夢と仕事を両立が
できないのかどっちか選ばなきゃいけないのか小学6ん
勝ちか負けが読まなきゃいけないのか
白星がクローバしか選ばなきゃいけないんだったら
我々は黒星でいい
そんなん team black したってございます
この上我々皆さんのために詩を書いてもらいました
ご主人の自分によって
ちら女に金持って
今すぐ
ji ね今
のショッ
ん
敵なしですね
きっと youtube の映像で僕にもちろんことがあります
皆さんも一緒に行きましょう
画面の前の面持ちです
あ動物大勝利なもんでいる
鳥さんも
ぞーさんじゃ
何かよくわからないと思いません
喜んでるん
さあ皆さん歌詞がありますからねぇ
歌詞でありますから
一緒に歌いましょう df ダンテを聞いて
何にゃんん
そうですこのソロに届くのだろう不思議ですねぇ
だけど
明日の妖精何かあった
分かりません
それ後そびえる橋働くんだ止める手段4ブラックと文句
car
ああああああ
ni ni
me
ano ano ko ni
goo
ben あの
ni
teame
me
そう tan
どこまでローン
ni
ani came
いいいいいいい
wh
coohem
ni
dare
dare
ああああああ
sore
me
yeah yeah
none
dai
ni
goo
me
he エロアニメ
ni
me
プードゥル後生地応援には超会議れてきまして家族でございました
本日の締め技としまして我々ん黒星商事代表取締役
全国市長会の皆様へご挨拶は賜りたいと思います皆様を切り端を致します
ええええん
ok
皆さん本当はどうもありがとうございましたん
チンパンスターズの強くと申します今日はどうもありがとうございません
僕らはですねこんなふざけた事をやってるんですが実際さっき
飛び回ったの学校の先生をやっていたり
らー皆起業家に努めていたり it 業界に染めていたり
実はこのチームの活動以外とは別で
みんな生計を立てている
仕事をしております
ここの卒業生なんですが卒業気に入っ変え解散したんですね
社会人なってい
エンターティメントで人前での泡沫してお金を守らない
できないだろうと諦めていたんですが
a
やりたいと思ったので
やり始めました
今ではですね
それに賛同してくれメンバーが
仕事も100%この活動の100%
脳みその中フルに使って発送しています
やりたいと思ったことですね我慢せず
環境に言い訳せずにですねー
全力でやって子どもたちから見てですね
大人ってなんて楽しそうなんだろうと早く大人になりたいなと思われるような社会を
つくれることが
ようになったらいいなと思っております
皆さんも是非
二かませず言い訳せずやりたいことを
やってほしいなと思う思います今日はどうもありがとうございました
9スターズのみなさんありがとうございましたいい
帰っていた別大丈夫です